back for the second day running and for
the first time an insight into why the
Duke of Sussex flew Halfway Around the
World to be here with his and his fellow
complainants witness statements made
public an insight into what they all
knew and when Prince Harry claiming two
private investigators have said the mail
paid them to hack his voicemail obtain
credit card bills and follow his friends
going on to say that the palace withheld
what was going on from him the
institution made it clear that we did
not need to know anything about phone
hacking and it was made clear to me that
the royal family did not sit in the
witness box because that could open up a
can of worms
for Mattress Sadie Frost an explanation
of how she felt suicidal and humiliated
at the personal level of detail revealed
in the mail baroness Lawrence whose son
Stephen was murdered alleging she was
subject to voicemail hacking her bank
accounts monitored and subject to Hidden
electronic surveillance as the
Publishers of the Daily Mail fight to
get the throne out of court they say
that a private investigators alleged
confessions which provides a central
part of the claimants case has since
provided them with a sworn statement
saying that he wasn't commissioned or
instructed to carry out any work for the
Daily Mail and they vigorously contest
the claims that are being made here in
Court Prince Harry also went on to
explain why he thinks what he describes
as a cover-up needs to go to trial
saying if the most influential newspaper
company can successfully evade Justice
then in my opinion the whole country is
doomed while the written statements from
Prince Harry and his fellow claimants
may be powerful and express how they
felt about the alleged attacking the
publisher of the mail continues to
maintain that their claims have been
brought too late to have their day in
court Katie Spencer Sky News